[Music]
riot riot of people
infiltrated this ex-president and that is such
a
cowardly idiot that he left two days
before going under the knife it was the United States that
's how it is but it's a riot a
riot that will be controlled it will
be  controlled, those who did this will
be punished Because this has big people
behind it.
wrong but you don't have to break it I
can't go to your house break your
house because I don't like you I repudiate
any previously democratic activity
because we have a
democratically elected president at the polls and
what happened to me was an
act [Music] an act
man
an act of curve da
e Unnecessary right because everyone has
the right to
enable their position and in case
no one wants to understand it says that the lack of
education is so great because when it was
i everyone respected it and now
because he can't respect it, he
needs to break anything, right, only if it were in his
place, accept waiting another four years
to see what he can do.
What
happened at the polls was real, right? We think
that the Suprema's finger is there for
something that's going on, right? So
we believe that we were robbed at the
polls.
the country
understood is to have gone back to the
crime scene to be elected and that's right being
President is absurd It's a shame
for the country about the demonstrations I
think they are unnecessary they are
applied against democracy a
Deputy against the Brazilian population  and not
at all This is a form of
freedom of expression this is an attack and
terrorism against the country an attack on
the population itself how much country
[Music]
please